roses been having a look at must Musk's
master plan part 2 rose well essentially
he laid out his ideas for the future of
sustainable energy and transport of
course what he's been banging on about
quite some time he says of course fossil
fuels expand to run out one day and I
guess if his plans work out Tesla and
him he'll on musk himself will be poised
in the right place to take advantage of
it essentially he's laid out a vision
where they're going to produce more
buses and bus rocket ride savings quite
something isn't it so we normally see
this as a gas guzzling part of the
transport industry but you know on his
plans of course they won't be he plans
to he said that in the early stages
development and they may unveil some
products next year and essentially
they're also looking at not just the the
way that they're filled but also
changing the design of these vehicles so
they can be more efficient and also
possibly taking he says taking
passengers all the way to their
destination I'm not sure that it wasn't
clear about how that would work whether
you go all the way on a public transport
vehicle to exactly where you want to go
or is that what happens now you know if
you get a bus well have you might go all
the way to well anyway I'm not going
there and then you can operate you can
you can summon them perhaps from using a
smartphone app for this is the way he
sees how public transport might work in
the future he also looked at autonomy
for example we all know that Tesla has
already been testing out it self-driving
vehicles and he said it's a long way off
but if they're working towards making
that a lot safer but eventually when
there are itself properly self-driving
vehicles you may be able to have a
vehicle that can help you save money as
make money and be more efficient in
general by summering the car when you
want to use it and when you're not using
it you can then put it into a fleet
where it'll operate within a fleet for
others to use and then you can use it
when and make it money exactamente is
cars between five and ten percent of the
time anyway now the thing is Solar City
is very controversial here as well he's
been trying to sell this one hasn't he
investors and not that convinced though
yeah so he says that Tesla should buy so
they said he's got a 22% stake in Solar
City but this all comes into his big
plan so he wants to make a solar panel
integrated into the roof type product
having SolarCity as part of the Tesla
family would help him to do this and
essentially you know that this plays
into the whole Tesla sort of idea of
sustainable energy now if you notice the
tesla website has dropped the word
motors from the name and it now says its
mission is to accelerate the world's
transition to sustainable energy whereas
previously it focused on clean
transportation so maybe a little shift
in focus there for Tesla to the wider a
more sustainable energy rather than just
transportation playing in with Elon
Musk's bigger long-term grand vision the
master plan bouncing some dates
grandiose with no time frame and no
specifics others say it's a genius move
into the future I guess some say
something in between